hey good well welcome to all of you
we're all delighted that you're that
you're here and I'm myself and excited
to do this second time around teach this
course faith in globalization what I
thought I'd do in this first part of
this this hour is give you a bit of an
orientation of the genealogy of the
course what makes the course tick what
we are going to be be doing and then
we'll have Martha Highsmith and Lucas
martha has meat in the back here Lucas
schweinfurt i was going to pronounce it
just about right was hesitating please
come in give you some information about
both about media and about security
kinds of issues i'll introduce you to
two TAS and then my colleague professor
ray who is going to be teaching the
course together with us we'll be giving
a historical overview lecture on the
issues concerning faith and
globalization so that's what we have in
store for today alas Tony Blair is not
here today but he's going to I trust
show up on September 15th so so here we
here we here we go a little bit about
genealogy I mean the course really
emerged from conversations with with
Tony Blair Tony Blair was very much
interested as prime minister in
globalization issues that was in men in
many ways very important piece of his
own political career and he is
interested in issues of faith and he has
come to believe that faith or I think we
should speak in plural faiths just stand
up here or sit down that's easier sit
down good he has come to believe that
fades we should speak in plural and
globalization processes are two most
important for
in the world today now I'm not sure
about the superlative myself where there
are there are the most important forces
in the world today but certainly there
are immensely immensely important and
maybe it doesn't look like fates are as
important from the vantage were very we
sit but look when looking worldwide that
certainly is the case now fades if fates
were simply about certain feelings that
one has say feelings of all or something
right in regard to the unknown if it's
were simply about a set of propositions
that one believes and which one can
prove right that's why they're called
fades some people say obviously they
couldn't have the kind of power that I
have but fates were always about a way
of life way of orienting oneself in the
world a way of constructing reality as a
whole placing oneself in that reality in
conceiving what is the good life what is
the proper life to live as a human being
and fades as such are enduring right you
can look at Judaism 4,000 years
Christianity 2,000 years Islam 1500
years and you can speak the same way of
Buddhism you can speak to speak the same
way of Hinduism empires come and go
fades in many ways remain any not it's
not just something about the past fades
continue to be a very significant force
in the world today they're growing
numerically in relative and absolute
terms and they're also growing in
influence so you have the fades as a
major force that shapes the way in which
people think of themselves of the world
and how to live in the world and you've
got on the other side globalization
processes and I don't think we need to
talk too much and too long about the
importance of globalization processes
not just the interconnectivity and
interdependence of the world that mark
globalization as we experience it today
but also I think the immense pace at
which these processes are proceeding and
are revolutionising all
most daily weekly or at least yearly the
world as we as we know it and so these
two forces coming together pose very
significant significant challenges now
so faith in faith and globalization my
own interest in that in that question
arises because you know as a theologian
what the theologians do of theologians
do faith right they do in a sense faiths
when I fly sometimes people ask me what
do i do and i say that i am a theologian
occasionally it sparked some interest in
the conversation but soon it Peters the
hot rock see what then I start talking
about well what do you do I teach
religion aha when religion was
prominently media even negatively it was
kind of interesting right and the
conversation will go on and then Peter
out right now if I say I teach religion
yeah a bit of a yawn so right now what I
say I say people pay me at Yale believe
it or not to ask these large questions
and questions who are we why we here for
as human beings what is a good way to
live once live and so forth and that
generates a bit more of discussion and
it tells you also a little bit about how
I conceive of my work as a theologian
it's not simply about what particular
group of folks believe or practice it's
really about way of life studying how
faith in my case is discretion faith but
also broadly construed fades multiple
place how they intersect with the ways
in which people live their lives leave
their lives how do they intersects with
the whole area of business and economics
how do these fades intersect with the
whole area of politics how do they
intersect with a broader and stood
culture and those cultural processes
technology media all of these things are
of immense interest in me one of the
reasons why I became a theologian is
that you can reflect on anything and
still be a theologian right and so for
curious minds like myself this was just
a great I was a kid in the candy shop I
could pick up any subject and I could
study it from theological vantage point
but you see my interest is in
section between faith and so faith and
globalization becomes a very important
issue I've done some work in faith and
conflict and this is obviously one of
the important areas or in terms of faith
and globalization because globalization
is stoneleigh will no doubt mention Mr
Blair I should say I will no doubt
mentioned brings people together but
fades often separate people before
because they define the group identities
of people and often in a position to
other groups so that fades globalization
processes and conflict is a very
important issue to study as well then
not just resources or not not just the
potential of faith to create conflict
but also possible resources of faith to
contribute to building bridges between
different cultures that too is an
important aspect of what we what we
study and I'm very much I've written on
this and very much interested in that
question I'm also interested in the
question of the relationship between
religion and human flourishing what are
the visions of human flourishing that
are embedded in religious convictions
religions as i said earlier are about a
way of life they are about interpreting
reality as a whole situating human
beings in that reality and asking what
makes up for life well-lived all
religions ask that question
globalization processes in many ways
also are about implicit at least vision
of a good life and I've come to believe
and maybe that's controversial maybe
that's something we should we should be
discussing in this course to but I've
come to believe that Phillip reef was
right when he said that our culture
Western culture predominant Western
culture and the culture that
globalization processes are spreading
widely is a culture of a managed
pursuit of pleasure and not a culture of
sustained endeavor to lead a good life
or lead the good life as defined by
foundational symbols and convictions our
culture's is a culture of the managed
pursuit of pleasure not a culture of a
sustained endeavor to get lead the good
life now if that's true and if
globalization processes are carrying on
their wings this type of culture then it
may not be surprising there are many
places religions faith in globalization
processes clash because religions if I
was right right and we're describing
religions are about sustained pursuit of
the good life now I don't think
necessarily we need to pose adversarial
relationship between globalization
processes and enfades I think within
globalization processes there is a space
for much more robust pursuit of the
sustained vision of the good good life
but that I think is one important
question that drives me as I'm looking
and studying this this issue and that's
also one of the issues that will run
almost like a red thread throughout the
course should we posed that question
should that be a significant question
for us to explore that's also what we
are going to be actually can be posed
that question implausible and robust way
in today's environment and how do we do
that in the context of religious
pluralism you don't have one vision of
the good life you have multiplicity of
visions of good life that often collide
I think those are the great issues that
we are facing in at the intersection
between faith and globalization now
we'll highlight some of these issues of
conflict as well as identity creation
and also the vision of human flourishing
throughout the course and we have
divided then the course in roughly i
think in four areas these four
areas are first in orientation about
relationship general relationship
between faith and globalization
processes faiths i should say in plural
always faith and globalization processes
this is the first part of our course and
then in second part of our course two
sessions on faith and conflict fates and
conflict fades and reconciliation and a
cluster of issues of conflict and
reconciliation then we have a cluster of
three sessions on faith and broadly
understood economic issues market values
in the market corporate governance and
questions of ally alleviation of of
poverty and then fourth we have kind of
kind of relatively amorphous category of
faith and culture and there will deal
with gender issues in globalization
process is very significant aspect of
globalization process human rights and
globalization processes rights language
being emerging as the new moral code of
the globalized world even though it's
true that a lot of people understand
quite different things and the rights
nonetheless the right function says
those was formally as that common moral
moral code and then globalization
processes and politics roughly the
question of the relationship between
faiths and democracy which i think is
one of the significant issues in the
world today and finally relationship
between religions so that's roughly the
outline of what we will be doing in this
course now I'm sure we could have taken
up many more significant topics and for
us as we were designing the course it
was always always the question what how
do you squeeze what seems to be the
project of a lifetime in 2 12 sessions
right something must be left out some
traditions end up being under emphasized
and we have shifted in the course of
development of the course from the first
iteration to the second emphasizing
different religious tradition geographic
regions have to have some regions have
to suffer right the being attended to
less than than others some topics have
to take the backseat for instance
psychologies know we're there to be seen
right but obviously globalization
processes are part and parcel of
creating a single global immense impact
or ecological impact and the two
processes of ecological impact of
globalization processes as well as of
religious convictions is a very very
significant one of the defining issues
of our age or technology as such for
instance is not being addressed media is
not being addressed directly all sorts
of issues of this sort and I'm sure
you're going to have a list of your own
which need to be need to be added and
you know as it happens I think the
course will probably have one more it
certainly have one more interation and
will have one more version will recraft
it and and hopefully we can we can
enrich it and find ways in which to
express the kind of the rich diversity
of that of that course of the topic the
discourse needs to address so roughly
now a few words about the structure of
the of our time together it's going to
be structured something like this that
the either professor ray or myself or
both of us together are going to offer a
few introductory remarks and those
introductory remarks will serve not just
to introduce a topic for a particular
session but also somehow to tie this
session with what went on before and
what is going to possibly follow because
one of the dangers of a course of this
sort is that it's going to splinter in
all sorts of direction so we need to
make sure that there is a kind of that
we always keep in mind where we are
are in the hole and how notwithstanding
all the disparate readings that you are
doing and questions that you're asking
how all these things somehow hang
together and make up whole so that's
going to be partly the function of these
introductory introductory remarks then
generally we will have either Tony Blair
is going to be present for five sessions
or we will or end we will have guests
who will come and we will give Tony
Blair or guests the opportunity to
address the class Tony Blair probably
something like 20-25 minutes guests
rigorously 15 minutes and that in order
to give you the opportunity then to have
a question answer period to ask guests
and there are some sessions I think
we're one of us will be giving this
second presentation rather than either
Tony Blair or I guess but for us to to
engage the presenter and the issue and
then we're going to take a break about
10 minutes ten minute break and we are
going to kick out our guests not Tony
Blair here stays because he's part of
the stable teaching group but the guests
we will do and then we will try to have
a seminar where we will address each
other and address specifically the
larger question that this session
particular each particular session is
asking is you will have I don't know if
you've read to have the opportunity to
read session descriptions they all
centered around a single what we think
is a single large and important question
and so what we're going to try to do in
this discussion period is to see in what
ways the kinds of things that we have
been reading for the class discussing in
sections listening our presenters guests
who came to in what ways do all these
things can be brought to bear on that
question that we are pursuing for that
particular day we found it important to
have a a single question not so much to
exclude any other possible question
but to have a single question so as to
focus our discussion even within each of
the sessions it's sometimes they're
overwhelmingly big all right and so even
there we need 20 in and limit ourselves
so the function of question did we
impose is for us to try and do that
hopefully these are good questions that
we are pursuing and as a result of this
course will try to possibly revise them
and you can help us revise them and tell
us why this wasn't the right question to
ask why we have to ask a different or
more precise kind of a question